- I always find it fascinating
- I twisted my ankle
a couple of years ago.
- With actors that I love.
I hear these stories of like,
sometimes right before they
broke big, they almost quit,
and I heard that that was you.
- Yeah, totally.
I mean, I think, my wife and
I had just had our daughter
and nothing was really happening
on the acting front for me,
and it just felt selfish to
sort of move forward with it
at some point.
And I guess, luckily, I
didn't have any backup plan
or skills whatsoever.
(Kelly laughs)
So sort of weighting it out
and trying to look for
other jobs here and there
that were not acting,
and then I had gotten
the "New Girl" audition,
and sort of went into that,
had already quit, (chuckles)
was looking for other employment
and thought that I would never get it
cause there were so many
incredible people involved in it.
You know, it's one of those jobs where,
you know, you have Zooey coming off of
a really successful movie career.
Jake Kasdan was directing in,
Meriwether had written
it and you are like,
well, I'll never get this.
And then I got really lucky.
- I think that almost helps
sometimes when you're like,
well, this isn't gonna happen,
so I'll just go in and have a good time
and then I'm probably gonna
quit and do something else.
You probably, that helped you?
- Yeah, it takes all
the stakes away from it,
and especially the personal stakes.
And yeah, I definitely
think it helped a lot.
- Yeah. Well, I'm glad you didn't quit
cause you're hilarious
and one of my favorites.